oh my goodness you guys I am at WWDC
right now and I just got out of the
actual event where they announced a
bunch of new things like the new 15-inch
MacBook Air we have some new software
updates for iOS 17. also Mac OS Sonoma a
refresh to the Mac Studio an all-new Mac
Pro with the M2 Chip and we also have a
new M2 Chip the M2 Ultra but my friends
what we are here for is the Apple VR AR
headset which now officially has a name
Vision Pro and it's going to be running
on an all new operating system called
Vision OS so Vision Plus okay we got it
we got to talk about it Vision Plus oh
God Vision Pro so Vision Pro is unlike
anything that I've experienced in sort
of the AR VR headset genre I got about
30 minutes with it and it was I don't
even know how to explain it because it's
something that you can't really explain
until you actually try it now sitting
there watching the event I was like wow
this is really cool you can have all of
this interactivity with different apps
there's all sorts of immersive
environments that you can experience but
until I sat down put the headset on and
actually experienced what it was like to
maneuver Windows to pinch and just bring
a window closer to you it was so
incredibly intuitive I I'm actually
speechless no just kidding I have a lot
to say on it so we'll keep going so the
entire interface it basically consists
of your surroundings and you navigate it
by using your hands your eyes and your
voice there's even a virtual keyboard
and it actually does have Bluetooth so
you can connect to keyboard and mouse
but they really have designed this so
you don't even need to use any of that
now the actual headset unit itself is
made of a singular piece of laminated
glass and an aluminum frame that curves
and wraps around your face now around
the frame there's an array of cameras
and sensors that all work together to
capture everything around you so it
understands your surroundings and
detects your hand input now to actually
maneuver around the interface you use a
few different gestures but how you
actually select something is with your
eyes and the first time that I did it it
was just like you looked at something
and it selected it these cameras and
sensors are what make all of the new
features possible including their new
way to unlock the device called optic ID
it's very similar to face ID on your
phone and Mac but instead of using your
face it uses your eyes now the straps on
the side have built-in spatial audio
speakers that are positioned close to
your ears that seamlessly blend in with
real world sounds the displays inside
the Vision Pro are pretty impressive
there's two micro OLED displays and each
one has more pixels than a 4K TV and
that means that the clarity on these
displays is so awesome and the fact that
I actually got to experience this was so
surreal we did this one demo where it
was a live action dinosaur and it just
the wall just opened up into this entire
environment and I actually was walking
around the dinosaur and it was watching
me I went and stuck my hand out and it
snapped at me and then I went around the
other side of the Dinos or and then it
followed me and it was just it was so
wild because it actually was following
me going into this I was kind of
skeptical even watching the Keynotes me
as a super wild Apple fan I was like
well am I Really Gonna use this like
What's it gonna look like is it going to
be comfortable and the actual comfort of
it it was it's still a little heavy but
as far as headsets go it was pretty
comfortable so the eye cushion also acts
like a light seal so it blocks out all
of the external light so nothing can
actually get in and the headband on the
back is super comfortable and it's
breathable and it stretches to fit your
head there's also the dial that lets you
make micro adjustments to fit really
well and the whole thing is a modular
system so you can switch out the light
seals and headbands to make sure you get
the perfect fit the controls on the
Vision Pro are actually very similar to
what we used with the Apple watch and
the airpods max there's a top button as
well as a digital Crown the top button
lets you take spatial photos and videos
and the digital Crown brings up the home
View and lets you control your level of
immersion with the environment as for
power they went with a cable system that
connects to an external battery so you
can actually plug it straight into the
wall for all-day power but with the
battery you can get up to two hours of
battery life now this little battery
pack is really nice it is so beautiful I
was like wait a second can we get this
just as an external battery pack with
USBC and lightning please maybe I don't
know now this whole thing is powered by
a dual chip design that combines the M2
Chip with a brand new R1 chip and the R1
is basically designed to handle all of
this real-time sensor processing it
takes all of the input from all of the
cameras and sensors and processes it in
real time to eliminate lag from the
experience another cool feature they
announced is eyesight this uses the
cameras and sensors inside the headset
to show the people around you who aren't
wearing Vision Pro a virtual
representation of your eyes this will
also let you make a detailed scan of
your face so this will let you use the
sensors to create a digital Persona that
others will see on conference calls so
people can see you as if you're not
wearing the headset another demo that I
really liked is if you have your Macbook
so if you're wearing the Vision Pro at
your desk and you open a few MacBook the
display will kind of just lift off your
screen and float into your field of view
which is awesome because I could
basically be working at my MacBook but
my MacBook is now a massive experience
in front of my face I think this would
be great for traveling I love editing on
a big screen but most of the time when
I'm traveling I don't have all of my
monitors with me so with this I'm going
to be able to have my full editing Suite
basically wherever I go now as I
mentioned the top button lets you take
photos and videos well with the Vision
Pro you can actually capture 3D photos
and videos it's hard to convey that in a
2d video so that's something I'm
definitely looking forward to testing
out I did get a demo of a piece of
content that was shot with the Vision
Pro and it was so awesome like I was
sitting here and then there was a little
family and they were blowing out
birthday candles and when the kids all
like reached in to blow out the candles
like the smoke just like went into my
face and I almost expected to smell it
because it felt so really holistic one
of the things I'm probably most excited
about is what Vision Pro was going to do
for entertainment and gaming now in the
demo in the keynote they showed you that
you can basically turn any living room
into a massive fully immersive theater
experience with a gigantic 100 foot
screen and spatial Audio surround sound
this also goes for Apple arcade games as
well and there will be a hundred games
ready to play on Vision Pro at launch
this is something that I could have only
dreamed about when I was a child and now
it is here in the demo I was watching
the 3D version of Avatar and it was wild
I normally don't ever watch 3D movies
because you have to wear like the
glasses and like the theater experience
just doesn't feel great but this didn't
feel like I was watching a 3D movie
because it felt like I was actually
there so the 3D experience was pretty
impressive the other thing that was
really cool is you can watch these shows
or movies in your element so I can still
watch it in my living room and then like
the background will kind of dim but if
you want to go into that cinematic
experience you can do that where
everything just sort of makes it look
like it's in a theater so you can do
both of those things and have those
options but it just was wow just looks
so cool now they have an all new OS
called Vision OS and this will have a
dedicated App Store with 3D apps created
specifically for Vision Pro as well as
compatible iPhone and Mac apps this has
got to be super exciting for developers
this is going to give them so many fun
things to work on over the next couple
of years now as far as price it is
coming in at 3 500 which is actually
pretty expensive when you compare it to
some other devices that are out there on
the market but like I get it though
because this is not like any other
device on the market right now and this
isn't something that I'm plugging into a
computer this is its own freestanding
device and at first I thought that it
was plugged into a phone and that's what
was powering it but no it's being
powered all on its own with the M2 and
the new R1 chip and it's gonna be really
cool to see what people do with this
they did partner with Disney so all
Disney Plus shows will be available at
launch which is great because there's a
lot of great content on there this also
makes me really excited because I have a
feeling that they're going to be
creating some special content that can
be specific viewed on this device during
the keynote Tim said that this is the
first Apple product that you look
through not at and I definitely think
that's pretty cool and having seen this
in person with my real eyes I just I
just I don't know like this is the
beginning I mean I don't think this is
going to be something that every single
person is going to go out and buy but
eventually when it does become more cost
effective smaller more portable than I
don't know I mean apple is definitely on
the right track with us what do you guys
think of Vision Pro I would love to hear
all of your thoughts in the comments
below and don't forget to like And
subscribe if you haven't already and hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos when I get Hands-On with this
thing you'll be the first to know about
it with that I'll see you guys in the
next video bye